so from the 8 news now investigators a
grand jury has indicted New Orleans
Saints running back Alvin Kamara and
three others for an alleged nightclub
beating happened last year Kamara
Cincinnati Bengals cornerback Chris
lammins and two other men facing
criminal charges all connected to the
incident outside of drays on the Strip
last February our eight news now
investigators first showed you these
surveillance photos from that incident
the victim was left bloody police saying
the men stomped on him more than a dozen
times kamara's lawyers telling us he was
defending himself the NFL allowed Kamara
and lemons to play last season a
spokesperson telling us today we
continue to monitor all legal
developments in the matter which remains
under review of the personal conduct
policy the men are due in court next
month